hello everyone welcome back to another
video by simply learn this is anubhav
and in this video we will be learning
about react and express js but before we
begin if you haven't subscribed to our
channel already make sure to hit the
subscribe button and press the bell icon
so you'll never miss any update from
simply learn
so without further ado let's begin and
see what's in it for you
first we'll get an idea about react and
express js after that we will see what
is react.js then we'll see the features
of react.js moving ahead we will be
learning about express js and its
features
and in last we will see how to connect
client side to the server side
every application consists of end
backend and the database together they
form full stack and in this video we
will be talking about react and express
js
react was created by meta and it is used
to make web application
responsive express js is annotated and
it is used to make apis express is
maintained by node.js
let's see what is react.js
react is a javascript library which is
used to build mobile in web applications
fast and interactive
it is an open source
reusable components based front end
library of javascript
basically with the help of react we can
create a client-side application or user
interface
it is a combination of html and
javascript
let's see the features of react.js
first
jsx it is syntax extension of javascript
with the help of react.js we can use the
extension to see how the ui should look
like
virtual of document object model dom it
defines how document are exist and
manipulated in the web page
performance there are several ways to
speed up your exact application by using
virtual dom
one way data binding information flows
in one direction react receive
information through arguments and pass
it by returning values
react goes beyond simple ui and has many
extensions for complete application
support
extended with flux and redux among
others
debugging
it is a small browser extension to make
debugging easier and faster
let's see what is express.js
express is a node.js framework designed
to build apis web applications
cross-platform mobile apps quickly and
easy it is very high performance fast
lightweight and unopenated expressjs is
used as a server side scripting language
let's see the features of express js
first
fast server side development with the
features of node.js express saves a lot
of time
middleware middleware is a request
handler that has access to the
application request response cycle
routing this refers to how an
applications endpoint urls respond to
client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
dynamic content on the web pages by
creating html templates on the server
debugging express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
now we'll see how to connect client side
to the server side
first we need to create a folder i have
created a folder named react express
let's see
go to your c file
here i have created react express folder
now we will be using a text editor in
this video i will be using visual studio
code let's open it
then
we will add all the npm packages and
create a react application called client
open terminal
new terminal
let's write some command
npx
react
app
client
enter
this will take some time
until then
just wait
yes so it's downloaded
now as you can see the client folder has
been created
with all the npm files
in this client folder you will see all
the npm files node modules
json file also
yeah now
we'll go to this folder
cd
client
now to get this application running type
npm
start
this command will start and compile this
application
now
it has opened a web page localhost 3000
this is the first client side
application startup page
this will be now working as a client
now
let's create a backend application for
that first
clean this terminal
let's open a new terminal
type
npx
express
engine
data
folder name
press enter
okay
now
this will take some time to install
press yes why
as you can see a api folder has been
created
now we'll go to that api folder cd
api enter
now we are in the api folder
let's install
all the packages in pm
install
press
enter
this will again download all the
packages
so npm has installed all the packages
required to run this
as you can see in the packages.json file
there are all the repositories and files
that i used
now let's terminate this terminal
terminal
now let's go to the client folder
cd
client
press enter
now we are in the client folder
npm
this command will start and compile this
application
now we'll see the standard express
application that has got installed
will again go to the terminal
delete this terminal
create a new terminal
and this
will go to the api folder
npm start
will start the terminal
press enter
now
we'll go to the chrome
localhost 3000
refresh it
you will see the standard express
application that has got it installed
with this we have reached the end of
this video make sure to like and share
it thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here